hi this is John Roca from Collider here
with the two lovely actresses from this
awesome film ready or not Samara weaving
and Annie McDowell thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us the first
question I have for you Samara is for
Samara this film puts you through a lot
I rewatched it again this morning what
kind of training do you do when you walk
into a film like this as an actress
alright okay good good know I did a film
right before this called guns akimbo and
we did four weeks of intense stunt
training so and I just finished that so
she used to had it in ya really lovely
and they wanted to make the fights look
messy and human-like because none of us
were the characters none of us were
fighters right so I think they made them
really human and did you take the yellow
sneakers did you take Gracie's yellow
snake no I'm acted what I know those are
great snake Andy I want to go to you
you've started in so many films from so
many different genres and now in which
of course speaks to your versatility
which is a great thing how much did it
excite you to try your hand at the
horror genre with a roll like this I
just love this script and I didn't I
really didn't understand how lucky I was
going to be what I was stepping into
because I didn't know anybody and I I
just fell into something amazing and
Samara is just is so such a hard worker
she works so hard and is extremely
talented and
I'm so just lucky to get to be in her
space and I really feel like everybody
that was captive cast really brought it
in I mean I feel like everybody was 100%
dedicated and and it's so well written
all the characters are well defined it
was perfect it was a magic really a
magical experience yeah what was it like
working with Antion smile I'm sorry I
was watching your amazing performance
yeah we had some good fights aim was oh
that one I love that thing yeah that way
so much things so much fun there was a
the directors were also very open to to
let us improv and just kind of make
things happen and and so a lot of the
scenes we're magical and the fact that
they evolved even though the scripts
beautiful and perfectly written and they
let you yeah yeah fill it fill it down
yeah yeah they made another great one a
VHS what they did with VHS was great so
to see them
keep going here with ready or not was
fantastic when I asked one question one
more question for you is what did you
fashioned this matriarch after anyone
that maybe you'd had experience with in
your life or anything near world no I
you know I it all happened I think
organically but I didn't know what to do
with my hair cuz my hair so curly and we
were working in Canada and it was gonna
be at night and I know they wanted it
sleek and it was gonna I'm I know how
long it takes to get it to look like
that you know we've never last so I came
up with this ponytail concept and then
they gave me this black dress which was
not what I was thinking and and then
sort of like everything so I was like
okay that's who she is and then
everything sort of kind of started from
that so much about the hair and the
makeup really expresses who the
character is one day so we in it
yeah you
the same thing the whole time so I
started from that place and then my
imagination just sort of sorted tuning
into who is this woman in relationship
to her husband much more than you want
to know I promise you but that's that's
where I was where it all started yeah I
love it the pulled back hair it's such a
great presence you happen everyone else
can flip out and do crazy stuff but
Becky stays solid and what she wants to
get out of this film is great yeah some
artists that you ran in Henry like
darling is there a scene that having
seen the movie I've seen it twice now
it's just so good is there a scene that
got cut from the movie that you wish
they had stated that it kept in their
like showed a little bit more of Grace's
journey you know my memories so shocking
okay uh when we're doing the audio
commentary with Matt and Tyler yesterday
they were like oh and then we cut this
scene was like quick so yeah I'm sure
that was but I I mean all right fair
enough
yeah with the babysitter now ready or
not what is it about the horror genre
that starts things starting to call you
here uh as an actress I think I mean I
was spoken a lot about this the
babysitter was sort of my big
opportunity in the States
and I think because that was a John Woo
film after that the offers were succinct
with that genre so I try and mix it up
with doing like different like TV shows
right in three billboards so yeah I
think it's really just the opportunities
that came gonna has one last question
with the military I know I got a wrap up
any one word for your experience so far
working with these guys on the film
mental there it is thank you both so
much for taking the time where do you
not go see this thing John Roca for
Collider